la radio a toujours eu un rôle
historique pour le meilleur et pour le
pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était un
petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu
hitler et ses potes la radio et puis
toutes les choses graves j'ai
l'impression qu'on les apprend par la
radio quand on écoute la radio on sait
si c'est grave ou si c'est pas grave
plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
et
nouveau samedi de mobilisation contre le
pass vaccinale au lendemain de sa
validation par le conseil
constitutionnel
dès lundi il va remplacer le pass
sanitaires pour accéder à de nombreux
lieux publics comme les bars restaurants
ou cinéma à ses opposants dénoncent une
atteinte aux libertés fondamentales
la situation sanitaire dans le monde
marque et au royaume uni par de
nombreuses démissions de soignants
épuisé par la pandémie alors que le
variant mikron est majoritaire en europe
la russie fait face à une nouvelle vague
et un nouveau record de contamination 24
heures au congo fait la vaccination
peine à décoller malgré la campagne du
gouvernement
[Musique]
série d' attaque sanglante au yémen
attribué à la coalition militaire
saoudienne condamnée par le patron de
l'onu mais réfutée par l'arabie saoudite
au moins 70 personnes ont péri hier dans
des frappes visant une prison tenus par
des outils depuis 2015 le conflit entre
le gouvernement yéménite soutenue par
l'arabie saoudite et les rebelles houthi
appuyé par l'iran a fait des milliers de
victimes civiles
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
retrouver sur rt france nouveau samedi
de mobilisation aujourd'hui contre le
pass vaccinale à paris notamment
plusieurs cortèges étaient organisées
celui des gilet jaune s'est rassemblée
place de la république un autre groupe
de manifestants est parti de la place
d'anvers dans le xviiie arrondissement
de paris direction place de la nation
pour beaucoup de manifestants la
validation du pass vaccinale ne change
rien à leur détermination
pourquoi c'est important faut continuer
en fait à se battre à lutter parce que
vous avez l'allemagne l'angleterre à
l'espagne en fait qu'on enlevait les
restrictions sanitaires alors
l'allemagne c'est encore un peu en débat
mais en tout cas l'angleterre et
l'espagne ont levé leurs alliés
restrictions sanitaires et donc on voit
pas pourquoi en fin de compte la france
continue en fait il est imposant
impasse vaccinale qui portent atteinte
aux libertés publiques à la liberté de
travailler là l'idée de liberté de
circuler donc c'est complètement à
contre-courant de ce qui se veut en fait
au niveau de l'europe en ce moment
j'estime que c'est le pass and iter est
une violation grave de nos libertés
fondamentales
droit à disposer de son propre corps
liberté d'aller et venir
et d'autres encore donc je le tout doux
les remparts qui devait préserver nos
libertés le conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel se sont effondrés et se
sont ridiculisés les unes après les
autres donc il ne reste plus que le
peuple a montré qu'il envie de défendre
ses libertés fort heureusement j'espère
que le peuple va bien se manifester
comme il faudra dans son choix
aux élections présidentielles on il est
aujourd'hui on est sur un pass vaccinale
qui va comme l'a prévu macro emmerder un
maximum de français et pas que des noms
vacciner parce qu'il ya des vaccinés qui
vont se retrouver dans le carcan
aujourd'hui des noms vacciner parce
qu'ils n'auront pas fait leurs boosters
et on se retrouve le bec dans l'eau et
ne vont pas pouvoir accéder à des
services à du cinéma des musées ou tout
autre chose en france c'est quand même
regrettable de voir un pays comme la
france mère patrie des droits de l'homme
qui aujourd'hui se couche devant abbasse
vaccinale simplement pour que certains
puissent pont d'un café debout
autre rassemblement aujourd'hui celui
des patriotes de florian philippot comme
tous les samedis depuis des mois ils se
sont retrouvés dans le 16ème
arrondissement de la capitale pour
manifester jusqu'au ministère de la
santé et précision de notre reporter
david khalifa qui a suivi le cortège
plusieurs milliers de personnes réunies
dans la rue une nouvelle fois pour
dénoncer l impasse de la honte les
patriotes seront motivés jusqu'au bout
malgré la validation il ya un an du
conseil constitutionnel pour se passer
vaccinale slogans hostiles envers le
gouvernement drapeau français flottant
dans les airs mais aussi des drapeaux
serbes en hommage à novak djokovic le
tennisman qui a refusé de se faire
vacciner qui je cite a refusé de courber
l échine se passe vaccinale pour eux et
liberticide et ne fait que diviser les
français ils continueront à lutter
jusqu'au bout pour leur liberté voilà le
motif principal de ce rassemblement je
vous propose d'en écouter à quelques-uns
on est toujours là ça fait des mois
qu'on se mobilise on lâche rien il faut
toujours mené le combat parce que se
passe est une discrimination on avait la
possibilité de faire des tests avant ce
n'est plus possible jusqu'à où vont
aller leur projet là on apprend aussi qu
ils ont allégé certaine mesure
c'est bien il ya des gens qui disent que
c'est bien et tout mais tant qu'ils
n'auront pas enlever le pass on
continuera le combat il faut continuer
la lutte je pense pour rien s'est passé
parce que ce pass vaccinale ne sert à
rien si longs mois et que voilà faut
continuer à être dans la rue si on
pouvait on serait dans la rue tous les
jours je pense ça fait plus d'un an
qu'on vient tous les samedis on veut
notre liberté la liberté de faire ce
qu'on veut des d'agir un mouvement qui
se veut avant tout un pacifiste ne pas
revivre l'épisode de la semaine dernière
où deux journalistes se sont fait
agresser le dispositif de sécurité a été
renforcée florian philippot condamne ces
violences mais pour le leader des
patriotes la véritable violence elle
vient inde emmanuel macron le
gouvernement se sert de cet argument
pour discréditer le mouvement des
patriotes qui est dans la rue depuis
maintenant 15 mois écoutez florian
philippot non on condamne les violences
évidemment mais on connaît surtout la
violence de monsieur macron contre les
français et qui les met à la rue qui les
empêche d'avoir des droits qui les
empêchent de vivre qui les emmerdes
comme il le dit et qu'il les traite
comme des sous-citoyens ça pour moi ça
me paraît infiniment plus violent que
les quolibets malheureux contre des
journalistes une manifestation qui s'est
déroulé sans accroc et qui est arrivé a
jusqu'ici place laroque dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris non loin du
ministère de la santé l'objectif le
retrait pur et simple de ce pass
vaccinale a dénoncé également une
dictature sanitaires et un gouvernement
totalement déconnectés de la réalité
le pass vaccinale est plus contraignant
que le pass sanitaire est inutile d'un
point de vue sanitaire selon pierre
gentille et avocat au barreau de paris
et marcel bénézet président de la
branche cafés bars brasseries du
syndicat génie
il n'y a pas d'obligation elle va faire
la faire le contrôle d'identité mais
nous nous sommes la majorité de nos
adhérents ne le font pas ils ne feront
que quand tu veux vraiment il en doute
nous 90 % de notre clientèle en ce
moment sont des habituées à paris nous
l'avons plus de touristes on a plus
personne non déjà nos commerçants sont
vides alors si on met des contraintes
supplémentaires voyez déjà quand vous
donnez votre pasta vaccinale déjà vous
avez l'identité du client dessus donc
elle est connue donc aujourd'hui ça
c'est une contrainte supplémentaire qui
a qui abat qui agace noon ou nounou
aveyron la restauration les bars et les
cafés tout ce qui est l'événement ciel
dans quel état on est aujourd'hui que je
veux dire c'est le patron de
l'établissement sont ont le moral dans
les chaussettes il est temps que ça
aujourd'hui moi je suis très positif je
pense commencer à sortir je peux
comprendre tous ces gens qui manifestent
je comprends très bien mais la liberté
c'est de faire ce qu'on a envie de faire
ils veulent passer leurs idées ils se
font pas vacciner quand je me suis fait
vacciner c'est mon droit aussi voilà
dans chacun est libre de faire ce qu'il
veut ben nous on n'est pas libre parce
que sinon canton et non vaccinés on est
isolé socialement et ensuite monsieur le
chantage entre soi c'est le confinement
soit c'est le pass vaccinale moi j'aime
regarder des pays qui ont fait ni l'un
ni l'autre sap a été le la mort partout
dans les rues la suède n'a pas confiné
la suède n'a pas mis passe en vigueur
dans ces établissements ou s'agissant
des déplacements et la suède ne s'est
pas transformé en mouroir donc faut
arrêter d'arbitrer entre deux mesures
restrictives et c'est à dire oh la la
heureusement qu'on a impasse parce que
sinon on serait confinée ça c'est du
chantage et là malheureusement je suis
désolé monsieur mais vous vous fait
avoir je vous le dis très gentiment par
le ce que ce que vous dites gouvernement
nous n'avons pas accepté toutes ces
mesures autre mobilisation ce matin liée
à celle du personnel soignant devant
l'hôpital d'instruction des armées des
jeunes est à l'appel de la cgt ils ont
manifesté contre la restructuration du
site l'hôpital d'instruction des armées
sera désormais réservé uniquement aux
militaires à partir de 2024 selon force
ouvrière du rhône 300 postes seront
supprimés ou redéployés à ces soignants
protestaient également contre la
précarité du système en france le manque
de soignants la fermeture de lits chez
leurs conditions travaillent plus
généralement c'est un nouvel hôpital qui
disparaît comme l'hôtel dieu en son
temps où il ya un hôtel de luxe qui a
été construit à la place aujourd'hui des
chaînettes il va être rogné il va rester
une centaine de personnels
qui sera uniquement centré sur
les besoins militaires mais encore comme
l'a dit le collègue il nous répondra
francs ils ne répondront pas tous les
besoins militaires et c'est c'est le
symbole l'hôpital desgenettes en pleine
crise est le symbole les foutage de
gueule du gouvernement vis-à-vis de la
population vis-à-vis des personnels
hospitaliers
c'est dans la même bottine et la casse
de l'hôpital public à savoir ça va être
un drame de catastrophe pour la
population qu'on interpelle la
population sur le drame qui va se jouer
sur leur santé l'amérique on est en
pleine crise sanitaire on est des
programmations des opérations cette
politique de soins et de garder un
patient le moins possible dans son
service avec un objectif qui soit sorti
au bout de 21 jours d'hospitalisation
quand on sait que la maladie
psychiatrique ce sera
ce one man 21 jours on se pose
sérieusement la question sur des
patients ils sont livrés à eux mêmes au
bout de ces 21
vague de démissions de soignants au
royaume uni alors que le système de
santé britannique est en manque
d'effectif depuis plusieurs années la
situation s'est dégradée depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire martial peu chiant
33000 c'est le nombre d'employés du
personnel médical britannique à avoir
démissionné entre juillet et septembre
2021 soit près du double du dernier
trimestre de 2010 9 celui qui a précédé
la pandémie entre épuisement et début de
dépression les soignants recherche un
meilleur équilibre
j'ai passé la première et la deuxième
vague aux soins intensifs à la fin de la
deuxième vague je n'étais pas bien je
faisais des cauchemars j'avais des
sautes d'humeur et on m'a diagnostiqué
des troubles du stress post traumatique
certains infirmiers ont vu leur charge
de travail augmenter de 25% pendant la
pandémie selon une enquête du syndicat
unison plus de deux tiers des
travailleurs médicaux ont subi un burn
out depuis le début de la crise
résultat plus de la moitié des employés
du secteur recherchent un nouvel emploi
des chiffres qui soulève de réelles
questions sur le système de santé
britannique
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à gérer
nous ne sommes pas des super héros nous
sommes des êtres humains nous avons
besoin de plus de ressources de bon
budget et de plus d'investissements pour
continuer à donner de bons soins sinon
nous aurons du mal
un appel à l'aide des soignants qui
réclame un plan d'embauchés massives
dans les hôpitaux pour faire face à la
crise
si le nombre de personnel diminuent le
problème que vous obtenez et que vous
avez un cycle négatif perpétuelle car
les faibles effectifs sur l'une des
raisons invoquées pour les départs
donc si vous commencez à en perdre
d'autres personnes penseront que cela
devient un lieu de travail de plus en
plus mauvais et pourrait donc également
envisagé de partir une crise il y a donc
un risque réel que le nombre de départs
ne fasse que croître l'effet que cela
aura sur les patients sera généralement
moins d'accès aux soins et une moindre
qualité des soins
face à un manque de personnel aggravée
par le variant omicron plusieurs
centaines de militaires ont été déployés
en renfort dans les hôpitaux et services
ambulanciers une solution à court terme
pour une situation qui devrait continuer
d'empirer sans réelle amélioration des
conditions de travail en république
démocratique du congo la vaccination
contrôle coville 19 peine à décoller la
population reste sceptique malgré les
campagnes publicitaires mis en place par
l'exécutif sandra chang ho
0,2 pour cent c'est le taux de
vaccination contre le coc vie de 19 à la
mi janvier en république démocratique du
congo depuis le lancement de la campagne
le 19 avril dernier près de cent
cinquante mille personnes dans ce pays
de plus de 100 millions d'habitants ont
franchi le pas parmi elles beaucoup
d'étrangers et des congolais qui
voyagent régulièrement à goma à l'est du
pays de nombreux habitants s'inquiètent
des conséquences du vaccin à long terme
d'autres n'en voient tout simplement pas
l'intérêt
je ne suis pas malade donc je ne vois
pas l'importance de me faire vacciner
contre le coc u19 je ne suis pas sûr
feront donc il n'y a pas d'intérêt à le
faire je n'ai pas le coc vie
dans les locaux de tena une radio
communautaire locale les journalistes
sont mis à contribution
si on afrique partout dans le monde la
vaccination est gratuite
alors tous maxime chaque jour ils
diffusent des appels à la vaccination et
des informations sur le vaccin en
français et en swahili mais là aussi ça
coince
j'écoute la radio ils disent que le
vaccin est disponible au congo et qu'il
est déjà comme il nous appelle à nous
faire vacciner contre le coc u19 mais
moi je me demande comment ils jouent
nous vacciner alors que nous le peuple
congolais nous n'avons pas de kobe 19 le
corona virus de type al je le vois nulle
une méfiance alimenté par les rumeurs
voilà le problème auquel est confronté
la république démocratique du congo dans
ce centre de vaccination ville le
docteur mouly chaud attend ses premiers
patients parfois pendant des heures les
gens ne viennent pas vraiment masse ils
viennent de personnes après l'intérêt
que ça marche ici il y en a qui disent
que les bleus veulent étirer
le responsable régional du programme de
vaccination au nord kivu se montre
malgré tout optimiste s'il affirme que
la campagne progresse il reconnaît
toutefois quelques failles avec la
nouvelle technologie de l'information
tout le monde a le téléphone la plupart
et soit des infos des missiles a qui
viennent de l'occident des anti vaccins
de théories du complot c'est toutes ces
informations là qui décourage la
population pourtant la plupart de ces
informations n'ont pas de base
scientifique début janvier le
gouvernement congolais a affirmé
poursuivre la sensibilisation de la
population
il a également rassuré que le stock des
vaccins restent suffisants pour couvrir
les demandes la fourchette de péremption
va quant à elle de février à juillet
2022 nouveau record de contamination en
russie plus de 57 mille nouveaux cas ont
été enregistrés au cours des dernières
24 heures malgré tout moscou épicentre
de l'épidémie n'envisage aucun
confinement son maire s'est entretenu
avec vladimir poutine sur la situation
sanitaire dans la capitale
je vous propose d'écouter les réactions
de certains moscovites
[Musique]
je ne ressens aucun changement pour être
honnête et je ne suis pas les
statistiques je suis donc surpris
d'apprendre qu'il ya eu un record
aujourd'hui il avait une change pas et
continuent comme d'habitude et je ne
vois aucun changement global je n'ai pas
peur de tomber malade pour être honnête
je n'utilise pas beaucoup le masque cela
ne me dérange pas je connais des gens
qui sont malades mais qui se sent plutôt
bien mais comparé cette maladie à une
fièvre ordinaire par conséquent tout va
bien
nicole et moi je dis stop il est très
triste qu'on n'arrive pas à combattre
cette maladie probablement tout le monde
devrait être vaccinée que dire de plus
bien sûr je suis consciente qu'il peut
vraiment y avoir un confinement les
cafés les théâtres vont par conséquent
fermé c'est ce que je pense bien sûr il
n'y a rien de joyeux dans tout cela
réunion mais ici c'est nécessaire
mira de nestlé atteignait après dix mois
de nouvelles restrictions seraient
catastrophiques je pense que cela ne
devrait en aucun cas se faire car chacun
décide pour soi même pour autant que je
sache maintenant tout le monde en
autriche est obligé de se faire vacciner
et de telles restrictions mon avis ce
n'est pas humain est certainement pas
démocratique un principe que nos
partenaires occidentaux défendent avec
tant d'acharnement à
l'autonomie démocratique
l'art africain
série d' attaque sanglante au yémen
attribué à la coalition militaire
saoudienne condamnée par le patron de
l'onu mais réfutée par l'arabie saoudite
au moins 70 personnes ont péri hier dans
des frappes visant une prison tenus par
des outils depuis 2015 le conflit entre
le gouvernement yéménite soutenue par
l'arabie saoudite et les rebelles houthi
appuyé par l'iran a fait des milliers de
victimes civiles l'onu et les etats-unis
appellent à la désescalade françois
tisci et beach
[Musique]
ils sont descendus par milliers dans les
rues de la capitale pour protester
contre les dernières frappes meurtrières
de la coalition militaire dirigée par
l'arabie saoudite
nous sommes descendus dans la rue
aujourd'hui pour dire aux agresseurs qui
ne nous est pré rond pas ne nous
humilient rompt pas et nous nous ferons
pas nous prosterner devant eux mêmes
s'ils nous ont assiégé
z
dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi une
prison de la ville de saada fief des
rebelles houthi et la cible d'un
bombardement aérien une attaque qui n'a
pas été revendiqué mais les outils
accuse la coalition d'avoir perpétré un
crime ce nouveau raid meurtrier
inquiète l'organisation des nations
unies
on nous a dit ce matin qu'il ya eu une
autre attaque des forces de la coalition
il nous sommes très préoccupés par ce
qui se passe et nous appelons à une
désescalade espérons le au retour à la
table des négociations pour les bacs
ce n'est pas acceptable et nous appelons
absolument toutes les parties à la
retenue l'escaladé du conflit militaire
ou jelen est vraiment très très alarmant
qui est l'énième et se vouer les
quelques heures plus tôt c'est la ville
portuaire de hodeida qui a été bombardée
par la coalition
une ville stratégique où transite la
majeure partie de l'aide humanitaire
destinée aux pays des frappes aériennes
qui interviennent quelques jours après
la revendication par les rebelles houthi
d'une attaque aux drones et aux missiles
contre des installations pétrolières et
aéroportuaires à abou dhabi capitale des
émirats arabes unis ces derniers sont
membres de la coalition militaire sous
commandement saoudien qui intervient
depuis 2015 au yémen pour appuyer les
forces gouvernementales
lors d'une réunion d'urgence ce vendredi
à l'appel des émirats les membres du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu a condamné
à l'unanimité je cite les attentats
terroristes odieux perpétré à abou dhabi
les voûtes si eux mêmes ayant revendiqué
la responsabilité de cet attentat il n'y
a pas de doutes quant à savoir qui doit
être tenu pour responsable
le conseil a clairement indiqué dans sa
déclaration d'aujourd'hui que davantage
d'actions internationales sont sert pour
faire face à la menace des outils et les
tenir pour responsables nous sommes
fortement encouragé par le fait que le
conseil a rejoint à l'unanimité plus
d'une centaine de pays et
d'organisations internationales pour
condamner fermement l'attaqué terroriste
des outils une violation flagrante du
droit international
après les attaques de lundi la coalition
avait déjà riposté avec des restes sur
sanaa la capitale tuant 14 personnes
fait rare le secrétaire général de l'onu
antonio guterres s avait déploré ses
frappes aériennes selon les nations
unies au moins 377 mille personnes sont
mortes en sept ans de guerre au yémen
et pour benoît me rationne président de
l'association acer il y à une
disproportion entre les condamnations
internationales contre les rebelles
houthi et celle contre la coalition
menée par l'arabie saoudite
là on l'a bien vu dans votre reportage
il y a quand même une
disproportion absolument scandaleuse
dans le fait de condamner les attaques
des outils le texte est très clair
en condamnant des attentats terroristes
donc ce qui est certain c'est juste et
le conseil de sécurité ne condamne pas
dans les mêmes termes
puisque là on peut considérer que c'est
un acte de terrorisme d'état ne condamne
pas dans les mêmes termes les
bombardements de la part d'
guillaume dides
en afghanistan des talibans manifeste en
faveur de la charia et de la loi
islamique ils étaient 300 hier dans les
rues de kaboul pour s'opposer aux
militantes féministes et s'est
régulièrement qu'elles organisent des
rassemblements dans la capitale afghane
est parfois au péril de leur vie sur
walid bennani
la loi et l'ordre des centaines de
talibans marché pour faire entendre leur
voix
une voix des puits spirituel selon eux
des talibans qui appelle les femmes
afghanes à respecter les principes de la
charia
nous sommes ici pour soutenir le hidjab
islamique dans notre société nous
voulons le hidjab islamique en
afghanistan ce qui ne porte pas le
hidjab sont contre l'islam
c'est contre la loi islamique tous les
enfants musulmans toutes les femmes
musulmanes toutes les femmes doivent
porter le hidjab
une marche en réponse aux manifestations
auxquelles a participé la semaine
dernière une vingtaine de femmes au
coeur de kaboul leurs mots d'ordre et
leurs revendications justice justice
elles ont très vite été arrêté par un
taliban armés d'une bombe lacrymogène
cette protestation semble avoir laissé
des traces dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi une militante qui a participé aux
dernières manifestations a été arrêté de
force à son domicile par un groupe de
dix hommes les membres de ce groupe se
sont présentées comme des agents de
services de renseignement talibans sur
les réseaux sociaux un porte parole du
renseignement talibans s'est exprimé
quelques heures après l'arrestation
il énonce implicitement de possibles
manipulations occidental certains
visages insulté les valeurs religieuses
et nationales afin de partir à
l'étranger les insultes aux choses
sacrées et aux rituels ne sont plus
tolérables pour le peuple il nous
espérons que les médias du pays
conformément aux principes du
journalisme s'abstiendront de publier de
fausses nouvelles et des rumeurs sans
fondement
le droit des femmes est au centre des
préoccupations d'organisations
humanitaires
human rights watch a critiqué récemment
l'accès de plus en plus limitées des
filles à l'éducation et à l'emploi le
président américain a estimé que
l'afghanistan n'était pas susceptible de
s'unifier un jour elle des propos
rejetés par le porte parole du
gouvernement afghan qui déclare que
seuls des nations unies pourrait
provoquer la chute des envahisseurs et
grands empires
retour en france à nantes avec des
violences et des dégradations constatées
en marge d'une manifestation anti fayer
soir cette marche contre le fascisme le
capitalisme et l'autoritarisme a
rassemblé plus de 600 personnes
des jets de projectiles ont été tirés en
direction des forces de l'ordre qui ont
répliqué par des tirs de grenades
lacrymogènes deux manifestants étaient
interpellés
des violences condamnées par la maire ps
de la ville tout comme la présidente ait
l'air de la région écoutez la réaction
de l'un des participants
on va essayer de à l'appel du collectif
faire bloc à ce jour et manifestations
anti-fascistes contredisent et sa droite
la sculpte en gérant parce que
voit dans l'espace médiatique grand
public et aux différents politiciens
d'être à droite combat devant
l'immigration l'islam nauséabonde et
hors de propos on est là c'est parce
qu'autant de
syndicalistes d'extrême droite elles ne
sont pas dans le court des travailleurs
et travailleuses parce que en gros les
scans droite propose la retraite à 65
ans ne déjeunent pas le smic les
consonances n'aime pas les syndicats on
reprenait ses droits ce n'est pas l'avis
des travailleurs et pour tirer au doigt
un délégué syndical grant west pour
alternatif police de la cfdt ces
incidents sont une nouvelle
démonstration de la mauvaise foi de
groupuscules violents qui s'introduisent
dans toutes les manifestations
c'est forcément d un raisonnement qui
est contre l'état contre la police donc
forcément vouliez que c'est quelque
chose qui ne compte pas entendre et
c'est quelque chose et aussi c'est un
comportement on va dire révolutionnaire
qui va pour s'en prendre à la
collectivité ça on ne peut pas le
tolérer et il faut savoir quand même que
quand on a le droit de la police a le
droit d'utiliser la force les gars pour
pouvoir dispersés sur sommation donc
quand on prévient la foule dispersible
le faire sinon la force légitime pour
pouvoir le faire donc ça vous dit c'est
aussi ça plus d'éventuelles violences
qui pourraient être commises à la marge
en ce qui concerne d'éventuelles
violences c'est la part il faut les
étudier au cas par cas voir s'y exprimer
quoi qu'il arrive ce qu'il faut c'est
que d'une manière générale les
politiques condamnent et c'est ce qui
s'est passé d'ailleurs
condamne fermement ce genre de
comportement qui nutriments d'ailleurs
il faut bien comprendre que la
population est excédée ce genre de
comportement et les commerçants les
commerçants qui subissent déjà une dure
crise je pense qu'ils ont un espace très
largement de ce genre de comportement
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité ce sera dans une trentaine
de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collectés vous le savez pour
moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative au sens du politique il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas la
public parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il ya
quand même la liberté